welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley clogged arteries anyway
from genetics you could have him he
could have him doesn't matter
yeah but you ain't helping your cause
yeah i mean jeanette you're pulling the
genetics card on us you're 400 pounds
you're going it could be genetics
okay yeah yeah yeah it's jeans nah my
great grandfather had him
split in the ass hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is are you garbage
goddammit
yeah it's a show we sit down with your
favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up to be
classy or if they're just a big old
piece of [ __ ]
yeah i'm your host dave sully coming at
you on a beautiful day we're down here
at aunt tony's base pootie she's doing
good
we love her she's a good kid my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
this is a wacky one today i'm normally
not this close to you on a
patreon you are you you are not we have
we have a little company and [ __ ]
special treat for you folks
he is not being compensated financially
i already asked
first time is a joke
i won't leave until i get money kevin
james ryan is right next to me everybody
hey gang thanks for tuning in you guys
are the [ __ ] lifeblood of this
[ __ ] show
we appreciate it the [ __ ] patreon we
just hit a thousand over a thousand that
thing's cooking too daddy oh so thank
you to everybody the [ __ ] support
means so much to us
you guys are the [ __ ] [ __ ] thank you
we love you shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good some of us at
least
me in general specifically i think most
attractive guy on the show
possibly fair enough t-bone mcmullen
everybody give it up for toby
mcmullen what up what's with the dead
stare
what i honestly i couldn't tell if you
were saying that you were the most
attractor or if i was
and i took it as he needs the most work
that is
yes thank you yes thank you ian your
psychopaths think alike i like it
yeah well you two get a room already
yeah we got one you guys leave
a couple more of those picks going
around and make a little something to
start it up in here guys just trading
some hogs back and forth before we hit
record
docking engage
gang this is a patreon episode it's a
bonus episode it's going to be a fun one
we thought it'd be fun to have our
incredibly special guest our good pal um
back again this will be i think his
fourth or fifth time
six fifth on the best fifth fifth
e whatever the two of you shut up fourth
or fifth whatever
he's got here on six can't come back
enough whether you want me or not
i'm here to stay and always when i'm
here it's the highlight of my week
some of the ian's last appearance i
don't even think this is going to get
released
ladies and gentlemen it's our old pal
he's our wacky neighbor
ian finance everybody hello jerry
hello henry you're our wilson we'll put
you up we'll put a fence up to your eyes
yes
the subscribers have voted they want to
only see half
uh hi everybody thank you for having me
i love being here
nice to see you too you three and aunt
tooty as well
and uh thank you for having me on this
is gonna be fun that's gonna be
fun today's topic of conversation
we we hinted to this last week is gonna
be field trips
and i figured you being delaware trash
yes must have had some interesting ones
yes
uh you know i'm just i'm
the shiniest diamond in the diamond
state now you went though you went to
private school right it's called
delaware's called the diamond state
delaware's the diamonds why and the
halfway house i lived in they called it
the diamond of the north
because we had the time bag of the north
yeah we had less people smoking crack in
our house so that was like this
is the good one wait a minute why is
delaware called the diamond state do
they mine diamonds down there
i don't know toby look it up i'm looking
it up why toby
is a producer yeah a lot of neil diamond
fans
because uh most of the state is uh
a piece of [ __ ] cold and you gotta
really squeeze it to get a diamond
yeah uh what is it kippy no it's the
blue hen state
yeah now delaware's the diamond state
i've never
heard that you're i am right and this is
a hell i'll die
okay i'm not saying you're wrong but i
thought it was always called the first
statement oh here it is the diamond
state
what on the on okay but on the license
plate it's the first state yes
so the official nickname is the first
state i mean delaware's so great it's
the first stage the smaller the first
one to irritate because it's got so many
nicknames it can be
you can erudery uh thomas jefferson gave
this nickname to delaware according to
the legend because he described delaware
as a jewel among states due to a
strategic location of the eastern
seaboard guy must have not traveled a
lot yeah no
[ __ ] tommy j not getting out of the
house name one bad thing the guy's done
he's a good kid yeah i'll wait a couple
of rough tweets back in the day other
than that he's all right
what's what's philadelphia yeah what's
philadelphia
that is first in flight well
philadelphia is a city so pennsylvania
would be the keystone sky
yeah pennsylvania is way trashier than
delaware no it's not
yes dude [ __ ] travel delaware is
where they call it pennsylvania
yeah okay okay up there you go okay yep
pointy and i'm not pointy
he thinks if he gets enough points we're
gonna pay him yeah
venmo ian dash finance uh you guys owe
me 36 points
wait hold on penn tucky oh you're a
[ __ ] idiot
you've never heard of pennsylvania i've
heard of pucks of tawny with
where the groundhog is [ __ ] you where
the rabbit is or whatever it is
that's trash what's his name yeah they
pulled a rabbit out to stump
punxsutawney phil puxertoni phil
delaware
is it is a state where companies go to
have shell corporations
to launder this is the second time you
brought this up today
where were you watching a movie or
something what were you doing patreons
don't watch it fight club or something
patreon stuff also you've been asking a
lot of questions about money someone's
in your ear about the corporate
structure of this yeah
uh hey for the patriarch can i get it on
unmarked bills your mom's on legalzoom
or something giving you notes
is he telling you what you're making and
giving it to you
uh yeah delaware is there's nothing
okay hold on i'm sorry there's nothing
redeemable about delaware both are trash
what's
what's what do you guys got an airport
or something no yeah
dover air force base in the new castle
county airport
unless you're flying an f-16 the [ __ ]
somewhere where do all our military
members fly out of and when they die
where are their bodies coming well why
delaware why do you think they put that
there
they put that there because they think
hey if delaware gets taken out all right
we'll keep it moving it's cheap land
yeah they're like these guys are already
checking they're not going to put them a
penthouse in center city
i know i delaware is i
i think what is your what's your cuisine
down there i think pennsylvania as a
whole
is trashier than delaware that's insane
no it's not no there are infinitely more
trashy parts of pennsylvania well it's
bigger
yeah it's like one big city it's just
garbage oh there's
there's north wilmington which is the
main city and there's dover which is a
capital delaware has
three counties uh nine tire fires
newcastle county sussex county and uh
kent county and uh eight thousand
mcdonald's wonderful beaches
pennsylvania's landlocked you know it's
where they debuted the kfc double down
yeah i don't know if i'd say wonderful
beaches i'm a dewey man
there it is i like dude we got dewey we
got bethany
we got rehobots we got indian river
indian river inlet rehoboth is garbage
we're hoping
the first openly gay beach acceptable in
america did you just try to big us up by
by mentioning an inlet that's what
you're going to get us with yup
the helpers are fantastic you should see
it at low tide
go go go crabbing in pennsylvania pal
it ain't gonna happen oh god here i mean
it's i'd go to the jersey shore like a
gym yeah and steal my crabs from
somebody else
you know where it's closer to to to
jersey shore than pennsylvania delaware
there you go okay dude i am so [ __ ]
dumb
i did not realize that delaware was
right next to philly new jersey
yeah i thought you're gonna say you
weren't recording or something like that
no i thought it was by like missouri or
something or some [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that's the thing people would
go i thought it was
from delaware they go what's it what
state's that in i'm like
you uneducated piece of [ __ ] the reason
you're trying to
yeah the reason it's trashy is because
you're so prideful of it that's what
makes it trashy well i think it's
because you got nothing else going on
foreign
it is wilmington blue rocks baby yup a
minor league affiliate double a
is that a kind of meth double a which is
something i'm also a part of
oh also on the thought of me being
really dumb
the the thought that i had outside was
when you guys were talking about the
sats in the last episode i've been
saying i'm getting a 980
and you guys and it wasn't but it wasn't
a 1350
it was out of the other one that you
said no it's either 1600 or 20 1600 or
2400
it was out of 20 16 you got a nine
that's like getting a [ __ ]
200 no it's not no there's no way you
got a nine toby you got a 900 out of
2400 wait is your helmet under the table
yeah what the hell you should have apple
sauce on your yes
are you from dover yeah no but that was
crushing when you said that because you
were like you're younger i'm the same as
her
and then oh such a bummer dude wait you
really got a 900.
i got a 980. they got a night behind me
jesus dude
foley beat you yeah fully beat you on
the essay what did you get on your sats
eight seven barbecue sauce
all right uncle kippy come on you're
giving him that
that was great holy you've never heard
that
no the oldest dad joke in the world i
thought you were lobbing me up for it no
that was incredible i thought we were i
thought you i literally thought you were
[ __ ] ooping me
i tell you these rubes from delaware you
can get them with anything huh
i mean hey got your nose yeah yeah
double side of fries
there it is ah
what did you get on your sats uh 11 40.
what'd you get 11.90 really not bad
and you got into you got into nyu
everybody we've had
75 percent of guests have said they've
gone to nyu it's a tough school to get
into
it's expensive too tough school to stay
at too yeah i had to take an extra
semester i
got a all incomplete do you graduate
from
you have a degree from nyu mm-hmm really
bachelor of science in english education
wow that's right you're a teacher
[Music]
must have been around real tight oh yeah
shaken right in his name i'm mr fighting
the very first did anybody have a sing
very first day
well you guys follow me on instagram the
very first day of teaching
eighth grade on uh in on like the upper
east side
i'm not going to mention the school but
all the kids were busting from harlem
and it was
you know i was the minority at the
school a teacher asked me
can you watch my class for a minute i go
to go to the bathroom and i'm shaking in
my boots because i work cowboy boots
that's a good look and a kid in the back
goes [ __ ] look like his name
lawrence and all the kids laughed at me
and i was like i'm [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] oh it was [ __ ] i forgot
you were too that
could be a good segue if it hits did you
have to go on any field trips with the
kids
ever oh yeah where'd you go how long
were you a teacher
i i studied and taught in college and
then i was a full-time sub
and then i took a break and i went back
and i taught ted it starts out as a
full-time sub
because it was hard to get a job as a
team what you do is you you're a
full-time sub at the school and then
basically you set yourself up to teach
yeah yeah at the school you're like the
in-house sub and then when it went and
opened
up yeah yeah and then oh well jesus
henry or someone leaves
yeah someone moves anything yeah yeah
someone gets their throats now are you a
six foot sub
um or someone pulls a chair and they get
asked to leave
he was a party sub but then he had to go
to rehab that's the truth
i was not hired again
[Laughter]
but yeah i was i was a full-time sub at
uh this one school
and then i for the new york city public
schools yeah and then i got a rep
is like a really good sub and i would
sub at different schools and i [ __ ]
lost it all because of drinking it you
could sound like you're eminem
and then you have a good rep yeah yeah i
could freestyle rap the kids you should
have seen me conduct a
game as heads up seven up uh yo man this
guy's giving out hall passes
oh dude they called me e-money because
one of the schools is progressive cause
you can't break
it for money oh [ __ ] here come here
could i please borrow some money hide
your chain here comes ian
you're riding around like debo
do you have any do you have any coins
i'm trying to make a call
yeah yeah can i borrow your cell phone
or sell it
sidekick for a second
the vending machine at my quarters i was
wondering if you had any change
i'm not gonna ask where you got the
money and i'm gonna tell you i probably
won't give it back
if he's not even doing it he's shooting
woody allen i'm doing it
i wish
sun yi finance over here
[Laughter]
can i borrow your retainer
is that a counter countdown for vacation
why is my birthday circle
you know if someone's so young you're
really cool
i bet you don't connect well with the
other kids
[Laughter]
are you sure you didn't skip a grade for
11.
for 11 you're very mature to be honest i
don't really know where we are in the
bed
i don't know who's or who's talking to
who
is woody allen a teacher or is it ian no
ian's about to ask an 11-year-old for
their snapchat
i don't know what's great i just don't i
[Music]
now do your parents look at your dms
snapchat deletes correct dude one time a
kid threw a bag of weed on my desk and
was like what do you think about this
cali kush and i was like i think if i
turn around and it's still there i'm
taking it home
i think it's about to be two buds light
so i i i take it around
you know oh that's great yeah it was
wild man
it was uh really something you were a
new york city public school teacher yes
and on top of that
i i stopped teaching for a while and
then i got a job teaching test prep
uh for kaplan hiv tests uh so i was
administered you were a kaplan guy you
said kaplan so i was teaching them how
to take the test
those guys are effectively keeping them
uneducated and
left behind which i was contributing to
the problem but i needed money anyway
uh so i taught i have i had a
i don't need my fat ass being dragged to
court i don't got a suit or nothing i'm
gonna [ __ ] testify against you
uh well you wouldn't fit in the box
uh please rise i can't he's the only
witness ever to do a skype call
and you run around
not that cheeseburger so you would take
kids on field trips
talk about a hung jury that one was left
in the air
holy [ __ ]
god damn i object to that joke that
lasted a whole semester
somebody's gonna put him in contempt
talk about a mistrial god
damn oh god i plead guilty for [ __ ]
timing
but uh yeah i dude i taught in so many
different schools throughout the city
how many years did you do this this is
before you moved to philly
and started doing comedy yeah and then
uh i went back to new york
and i was teaching kaplan from jesus
uh 2013 until 2016.
that's like tutoring though 27th 2017.
i i would be in schools from anywhere a
month to four or five months
multiple schools so i'd go and teach
from like nine until one and moving
around like a shady priest and they
teach from three to six within my new
idea
mr schwartz got a go bag
you look a lot like the [ __ ]
like grab my hat
no that was lawrence
do you have any kush
oh my god yeah where would you take kids
on on field what were some field trips
because today's the big field trip did
you hear toby make out points
wow you're not [ __ ] slow after all
holy [ __ ]
oh that's so [ __ ] under the bleachers
have you kids ever wanted to see the
stars
mr finance aren't supposed to the rest
of the kids be on this field trip with
us
no martin you're going a field trip to
outback steakhouse
why don't we go on a field trip on
valentine's day this is weird
why are you wearing a clip-on tie why is
this permission form asked for consent
all right well we've officially
exhausted this uh
unnecessarily
we'll do a call back in a couple of
minutes to put some life back in this
thing oh
[ __ ] that's one thing the kids never
would do come back
where would you go man
well when i was doing kaplan i wasn't a
full-time team so i'm aware of that
school or whatever but i brought uh a
group of first graders
to uh here we go
through a museum i forget it was on
staten island i forget which
what is it
you took a group of first graders to the
teamsters [ __ ] music
does anyone know where jimmy hoffman
does anybody know where he
does is know the phrase rubbed out
[Laughter]
no i i spelled bay of pigs
that wasn't italian you're thinking of
bayonne
the bay of pigs was all connected i mean
yeah sure that was a jump but yeah
well yeah that joke wasn't connected
hey gang quick announcement from one of
our new sponsors over here on the
podcast
it's hellofresh baby the big dogs with
hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun
and affordable baby that's why it's
america's number one meal kip
hello fresh cuts out the stressful meal
planning grocery store trips
so you can enjoy cooking and get to the
dinner table in about 30 minutes or less
i hate going to the grocery store every
time i'm there me and my wife we end up
fighting because i want to get this she
wants to get that my anxiety kicks in
just cut out the middle man go to hello
fresh you can try meals ready in 20
minutes or less
lightening prep recipes and quick
breakfast and lunches perfect for your
busy
schedule guys hellofresh has a wide
variety of easy delicious options for
all three meals of the day we're talking
breakfast lunch dinner plus they got
snacks and special treats
in between they sent us uh they sent me
me and the lady uh a box of this stuff
and i got to tell you it's a game
changer i'm an idiot in the kitchen i
barely know how to make a bowl of cereal
i'm i'm a real bozo and they turn me i
feel like a pro i feel like i remember
legacy in this thing you know i'm doing
a little dash of this
a little spice it add a little flick of
this i feel like i'm a michelin star so
guys
get it it's easy it's really good it's
better than anything you can whip up on
yours
on your own i bet um so go to
slash hellofresh.com 12 and use promo
code garbage 12 for 12
free meals baby including free shipping
i ain't talking two meals i ain't
talking four meals i ain't talking six
eight ten meals i'm talking 12 free
meals go to hellofresh.com
garbage and use promo code garbage12 for
12
free meals baby do it
also another word from one of our great
sponsors is the good folks at better
help
guys they've been a sponsor for a while
you know them
uh better help that's h-e-l-p and
uh is this you know these this is uh you
know counselors online i for one have
been going to a therapist for a while uh
and it's really a game changer in my
life
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
i know when i was doing comedy i i i i i
really needed someone to talk
through my issues my problems just to
get your head on straight so you're able
to do what you need to do
and with betterhelp.com they'll assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
it's not a crisis hotline it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely
online and you can start communicating
in under
48 hours baby if you need some sort of
expertise you know what i mean if
you're not looking for somebody running
the mill and you can't get the expert in
your area
they may be available to you on
betterhelp.com so check it out the
service is available for clients
worldwide uh you can log in anytime and
send a message to your counselor
and you'll get like you know timely
thoughtful responses
and plus you can schedule weekly video
or phone sessions
and you never have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you would
with traditional therapy i did that when
uh i was seeing a uh i was seeing a
therapist that a lot of
other comics saw and you would hear the
other comics in the room because the
walls are paper thin and then you're
sitting there looking like an [ __ ]
you hear them you know the person behind
you can hear you it's just
not a mess with the pandemic it's
changing things betterhelp.com is the
way to do it and they want to start
helping you live a happier
life today so visit their website
betterhelp.com
reviews you can read reviews from all
the testimonials that are posted daily
of everybody
that has used it it's you know take it
take a look for yourself
and betterhelp.com garbage that's
betterhelp.com
h-e-l-p better help help dot com
garbage and join over one million people
who have taken change of their life
who have taken charge of their life and
mental health
uh to help and got experienced
professional help
uh it's available in all 50 states uh
special offer
for our listeners for all you garbage
you get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage one more time guys
write it down if you're looking for a
counselor if you've been thinking about
it been kicking the tires
this is the way to get in it's easy
peasy do it from your home that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p dot com slash garbage
for 10 off your first month now back
to the show um no i took him to this
museum and i'll never
forget i had to leave the room because
one kid was like there was like a bird
and he was like do not touch and he goes
look at the bird and he touched it his
head fell off
like it was like a display oh
the yeah started crying the other
teacher had to go and fix it i had to
leave the room i was laughing
these kids won't return my calls or pens
[Laughter]
ah yeah what did you have what did you
go to
as a kid like what was it delaware the
delaware boot factory
the chemical plant the paint plant
did you go to dupont then a plant no i'm
trying to think of field trips one field
trip we went to philadelphia
i was in second grade you went to the
franklin institute yeah
i went to the liberty bell my i remember
it was such a big deal my parents had to
talk and they're like we're gonna give
you five dollars to get whatever you
want in philadelphia and i was like
he still has it hey teach which way is
north philly
[Laughter]
the liberty bell the only thing with a
crack
um i think in my future i remember i
spent on a hot dog
that's okay i want a fake what'd you do
constitution
um and uh yeah went to the liberty bell
in like second the franklin for the
fight for the listener franklin
institute was like uh like the ben
franklin it was like a science thing
right franklin institute was for the oh
yeah yeah i'm thinking the franklin mint
yeah yeah yeah you know the franklin
institute was like it was like a science
thing there was like yeah
about that was
like disney-esque thing like there was
like dizzy yeah it's just no roller
coaster no
no but i mean like in the fact that
there was like displays kind of it
wasn't like a museum it was like an
internet it was like more interactive it
was like chucky it was like chuck e
cheese for history
yeah you know they had the whole they
had the big heart sorry i offended the
disney the [ __ ] walt disney family
estate well you're making me
they had everything kites string that
was choking
uh i remember the heart you would climb
in do you remember wait climb to the big
heart
yes now we come back flooded with so
many field trip memories
yeah that was the first time i've ever
had rock candy ruined my life they're
gonna say first time ever in rock
[Laughter]
i got to ride the stint
[Laughter]
ah i hope i go on the table just to
haunt you
[Laughter]
that's a great joke that'll stand out
it's a picture of foley with his face to
the aorta
oh [ __ ]
that was a that was the big one and then
when we was the big one i know but i
think you
probably missed it because i guess when
we were in like late elementary school
they put that big screen
in did you get that there was like the
4d movie
i remember we went to the planetarium
down there no this was like you flew it
was like a big
huge [ __ ] movie screen that like if
you were like on a helicopter flying
through and it would like get people
would get sick it was like a huge ride
had to get the helicopter in there no it
was like footage
oh okay i don't know 980 over here
check out the helicopter
jesus christ i didn't know ben franklin
was a pilot
if it's a used car how to get on the lot
but that was a yeah i didn't get that
one
holy [ __ ] i saw like
a disappointment in his eyes
he was not here mentally or emotionally
i don't think
he was [ __ ] he went
oh my god i looked over your eyes or
just glazed i saw a [ __ ] dog tied to
a tree
i [ __ ] i mean remember when i had one
point
can we go back to that jesus christ
uh i don't even know what we're talking
about i just had a [ __ ] flashback oh
man
i'm talking about the franklin institute
that was the classiest of
all field trips in the philadelphia area
uh yeah some of the [ __ ] real shitty
ones we did was we did
uh we did amish country that was big for
us yeah we just went out
my family was friends with an amish
family
i spent thanksgiving on an amish family
farm
homeless
my two friends were elam and emma oh man
they probably hated you
i used to wear plain clothes to not rub
my lifestyle in their faces
so you can't use light switches i take
my shoes off and shovel [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] you know carriage with them and
everything it was awesome
how do you meet amish people uh my
grandparents would go to amish country
they were very talkative
you know warm people they got to talk in
one of the the pie cellars
and then uh they they could do a nickel
for the pie
you don't really use money
[Laughter]
it would just be a waste if we gave it
to you and you can't eat all these pies
save money by making your own clothing
do you
uh so yeah my family became friends with
an amish family and we used to go up
there to visit we had a thanksgiving
with them i tried to shoot
a turkey i we shot the own turkey i was
banned with a shotgun but also artists
in fifth grade
[ __ ] not allowed back in the acme
y'all see turkey around here
oh my god dude here's your trash
no i'm cultured i was a rabbit hanging
out with amish people is not
cultured i did it for the network
purposes
we got them riding in our car it was
[ __ ] awesome yeah now they're not
gonna go to heaven
who wants to take a run who wants to
take a ride to my station wagon to hell
hey schliam
holy [ __ ] let's take your wagon to hell
kids who wants to meet the devil
[Laughter]
put down that bible come take a ride in
a pickup truck
do you like gasoline god can't see if
you [ __ ] me in my ass
they're [ __ ] in the back of the
pickup what toby
hold on
[ __ ] christ i feel good but you don't
look good
that's because he's losing blood i
can't feel from the waist it chills me
down a little bit
it's like having your own air
conditioning
oh [ __ ] if i get hot and still take my
heart medication
condensation's coming off your [ __ ]
forehead
i'm like a hotel room
now this one's stuck on cool
keep the window unit in all year round
oh
god it hurts
[Music]
oh man
[Laughter]
hey kids you want to meet the devil
you've actually spent
thanksgiving that's nuts don't do
thanksgiving
yes they do they give thanks
i it makes sense to [ __ ] the warlock
that broke
them i mean they came here from europe
yeah but they don't they don't subscribe
to the pilgrims they don't subscribe
they just never advanced
yeah they have a very old traditional
style of living
and giving thanks and being grateful is
part of that tradition
yeah but dude we would be in that i was
finishing everything
everything was heated by stove they all
talk in you know this germanic language
yeah you know it would be cool to do now
can i tell you
i would like to do it now they're
probably saying these bozos from
delaware showed up again
i can't get them to [ __ ] out of the
house so your shoes are wooded
that's probably low cost can i tell you
the [ __ ]
gran the patriarch of the family was uh
you know they're all carpenters it's
like really cool whatever
but the patriarch of the family could do
some like amish thing
what's it called when you put the rods
in your hand you find where the water
line is
the water line yeah you you find or like
energy or whatever
i was such a misbehaved kid wait what
look i just just it was all fun
how do you propose them yeah i don't
even know what you're talking like
back up give me like one more this was
some this was some type of
metal metal rods energy
[Laughter]
some amish guys ploy to molesty and it
always always pointed out my penis
holding copper
okay it says ian's an idiot i got you
dowsing rods
yes dowsing raj for feng shui
it's it's a way of finding energy points
where you you then find negative energy
and you put up like some sort of blocker
they were putting backs on you yeah no
[ __ ] there's a way to find kids that can
keep their mouth shut i was such a bad
[ __ ] kid we had these amish people
come down from lancaster to my
grandparents
try to get the negative energy out of
the house after you were there
yes like it's like it was like an amish
exorcism i swear to god
they got a pair of his underwear but
they throw gravy everywhere
ian's going let me show you a trick
first they cover the house in dumplings
and then
so so they hot my grandparents got the
amish to come to do these energy things
and then they got these black jamaican
baptist
women to come and say like [ __ ]
speaking tongues what are you [ __ ]
damien what are you doing
i went through a lot as a kid
i was on it so it wasn't enough double
the dose
so we're trying everything and we're not
kidding i'll never forget we were in
like the
like what's we were in like some room in
my grandpa
like the real like the not the dining
room not the living room
the [ __ ] room that everyone hangs out
in the family room living room dining
room
whatever we're in the [ __ ] family
room padded room we're all it's only the
kitchen in the bathroom
you act like it's a big mystery i don't
know what's it called
[Applause]
you can't be bothered i don't know
what's it called
the couch the couch we're on the couch
so
we're in there and and we're all huddled
in a circle and we're swaying and
they're doing these like baptist prayers
oh my god and they start speaking
imagine being such an annoying kid that
you have multiple [ __ ] religions
driving
[ __ ] i felt so bad about this that
they were doing all this work
that i started to make myself shake to
make them think that it was working
and the woman's like look look look it
works
and i [ __ ] faked the funk and faked
them out and they thought they [ __ ]
saved me but guess what
am i evil you start singing a george
clinton song oh my god yeah it was wild
you know yeah man i i look man
my family went through a lot i was you
know a rough and tumble kid
i didn't really deal with certain things
too well and uh what do you want from me
so kippy you went to ben franklin
anybody go to the aquarium
this is on the patreon i don't know if
it is
[Laughter]
you gotta take the cadillac out a couple
of times you know what it is
hey gang one more time i want to tell
you about sheath
underwear.com the good folks at sheath
underwear i mean you know them
you love them we love them it's the only
underwear i will wear
anytime shitty underwear is a young
man's game the people listen to this
what are you doing get your act together
and get some sheath
give it a try just once i guarantee it
it will ruin
the rest of your underwear you won't be
able to put it on you'll feel like
you're in the 1700s putting some
baggy clunky cotton piece of [ __ ] on
this is talking modal and spendex baby
and it's got a dual pouch
to separate for separate compartments
for your ball bag
and your little pp whatever you want to
do it's easy peasy
um they got a cool waistband that makes
you look cool and plus it gives you an
extra you know it makes you look like
you're packing when you're not and if
you are packing it makes you look like
you're really [ __ ] packing you know
uh sheath underwear has been a supporter
of this pod uh
forever the the he's a great guy he
reaches out
we deal with the owner directly he's a
he's uh
a war veteran for the u.s i mean you
know he he came up with this while he
was in
while he was overseas in the desert and
he could get his balls off his leg and i
tell you
he's made my life better by doing it so
guys check out sheathunderware.com
use promo code garbage for 20 off that
sheath underwear.com
code garbage for 20 off your order today
support the people who support
the pod if you know what i mean also
shout out to the good folks over there
at fume fume took a look around the
world and noticed the solutions to quit
smoking like patches
nicotine inhalers vapes the whole nine
yards stunk
and we ain't having it so what they did
in response
fume handcrafted these beautiful wooden
pipes that make quitting process
simple easy and even desirable uh
it's not some shitty vape it doesn't use
nicotine no nicotine that's what they do
but instead they use coors and fuse with
the world super plants that are known to
successfully
successfully help you quit from start to
finish
plus they taste pretty fantastic too
they sent them over to us
me the big band t-bone we're all trying
to get off the bernies listen
being on bernie's for forever ain't for
long-term ain't sustainable
you got to try to cut back or at least
get off him and
i know i was done i had quit for five
years and then picked back up because i
went to a shitty wedding and that's what
you do with shitty weddings
when you get drunk you start having a
couple of bernies next thing you know
i'm back on the horse i try not to smoke
at the house i don't smoke at the house
i leave
i leave uh the fume at the studio and
bob right before we record between
episodes after we record that's what i
do to take the edge off because when i
need a bernie kippy needs a bernie and
the fume
helps me take the edge off and not have
a bernie
i'm telling you guys check it out fume
has already helped over 30 000 customers
worldwide
with hundreds of customers who have
shared their story on their website so
check it out head to breathe
fume that's breathe b-r-e-a-t-h-e
fume f-u-m and use promo code garbage to
save yourself ten percent and help you
or a loved one quit today one more time
guys
breathefume.com that's b-r-e-a-t-h-e-f-u
dot com use the promo code garbage to
get yourself 10
off and help you or a loved one quit
today now back
to the show yeah yeah it was a while oh
god hanging out with amish so yeah i
promise jamaican [ __ ]
tongue speakers i know i've lived a life
i can kind of see what you're saying
that you know delaware is classier
[Laughter]
christ dude i swear to god my mom was
getting rid of a bunch of we had like a
garage sale
and they came down to like help us clean
it out you know
and uh jamaicans are the homies no the
um jamaicans are long gone
that my mom [ __ ] god blessed my mom
she keeps going
you want this lamp i'm getting rid of
this lamp i'm getting rid of this stereo
[ __ ] she keeps forgetting
you kids like star trek right do you
want my beastie boys cd
hey you want this this land
oh my line you ever see a battery before
yeah
yeah man the fight dances something else
he cut from a different cloth amish
country we lived with an amish family
for three years i went to amish reform
school
did you didn't work no henry taught you
to put up a barn
i'm just [ __ ] woody harrelson i drink
semen and chop a horse's hopes off
whatever sorry i i've lived an
interesting life have you ever been to
the aquarium i lived under the sea one
time
[Laughter]
we helped dolphins move little mermaid
was about my mom's life
dolphins move from one tank to the next
oh i pictured them in the ocean my mom
kept saying do you want these gloves
and i was saying ian's doing
high-pitched squeals
holy [ __ ] i imagine the food at that
thanksgiving
picking up on everybody that comes in in
contact with the finances trying to get
away from them quickly after
oh and then exercise
it's not good enough just to ask you to
leave they have to torch the place
i guarantee you the second you were
pulling away that whole farm was burning
to the ground
let's turn it here let's go back to
europe it can't be as bad as the
finances
we'll face the king i don't care
i don't know what year it is winter's
coming
let's get back
you've never shot your own thanksgiving
turkey you haven't lived
the food we get ours killed that day do
you buy the amish probably
i don't know if it's the amish but yeah
it's you know it's delicious
what you're getting killed that day that
day or the night before yeah they go
like pick it up like yeah
i mean we don't like do it my step dad
knows he's full of [ __ ]
i'm serious gets it at acme yeah oh we
killed it
he's got butterball written all over
[ __ ] easter bunny like poop dad those
are raisins
no i'm serious i don't know i mean i
don't know i don't have any evidence to
pull myself out of this
i mean you're gonna have to take it
unfortunately we're gonna need some
otherwise we'll continue to [ __ ] on you
all right it's fine
i'm just saying you're both looking i
leave my tooth under the pillow my dad
says i'll get a quarter
ian once half of it
see what you could get your dad gives a
quarter
starts punching himself 1-800 dentures
these nuggets were killed this morning
where we were god i don't know but i'm
sorry you're lying about your
thanksgiving
yeah yeah you get it that day yeah i'm
seeing it first of all it doesn't work
like that you have to age it for a
little bit
what it's not [ __ ] wine what do you
got to process it
you can process it no the whole idea of
natural turkey
they get it from a farm in bucks county
and like and then they deep fry it like
gentlemen
no no and then my stepdad goes like the
day or two days before
and like two days here we go he goes no
no no he goes that one he they pick it
you make it sound like he walked into
your house like joe pesci and goodfellas
and you popped him in the back of the
head i'm gonna let you hang it on that
one
yeah right when you start talking i was
like this is gonna be not good
to eat in the proofread
can we get some edits on this that was
the director's kind of i had a real bad
one a couple minutes ago
[Laughter]
i was already planning my escape i was
gonna flip the table and run out the
door
oh that's how he kept hanging without
the lied about that yeah
he yeah put the pointy gun at someone
else
[Music]
yeah i really thought that joe bishop
what are yeah talking about i don't even
i don't even know oh god
we kill our turkey after we eat it so
how about that [ __ ] face
what i can
kill the rift that's jesus christ
killer killer that joke was clocked
fifty percent
oh my god nothing on that that deserve
better come on
you put a snit in that joke give it some
legs shoot that thing like a turkey
he's not beating his ride the stint joke
come on all right deflect will you
oh [ __ ] god damn it i'm so hungry
some turkey oh yeah some nice uh
toby let's go grab us some amish turkey
and just grab an amish are you ian
they run out yeah if you guys need to
break
and drop in some canned themed music i
might need a breather play the jeopardy
tunes
um too funny i mean we gotta
do do we attempt to shift back to
[ __ ] uh well of course
yeah of course so have you ever been
[Laughter]
we went to the edgar allan poe house
what do you want to see how you're going
to die
i don't get it on the street bloated i
don't know much about the man
but i had a terrible alcoholic fat dad
okay i'm in i'm on board with age mode
joke everybody
he gave me the footnotes and over here
the uh checked out oh god
[Music]
i just watched a raven with john cusack
it actually wasn't that bad yeah um
thanks siskel he died in baltimore
though not in philadelphia but he lived
in philadelphia for a brief time
where they believe he wrote his hit poem
the raven
we got another hit poem coming up here
um
[Laughter]
stay tuned ernest hemingway coming up
after the break
top of the charts the one that i didn't
go to but everybody went to
in our area i don't know why i didn't go
the gym
the health food store the [ __ ] is the
whole foods
that was the hatfield plant that was big
the padfield ham
like the pam products yeah
oh i thought you were maybe hers potato
chip factory
no we didn't do that we i used to work
with a guy who was married to the heir
of the her
fortune choosing her yeah she was a her
yeah progressive and rich that's a lot
of [ __ ] cash oh
yeah this guy was [ __ ] filthy loaded
huh he didn't even really care about the
job he was working
wait would you no would you get out of
bed
i would meet him yeah yeah i mean come
on
i'm [ __ ] running on fumes lucky he's
here [ __ ] red eye today
i no but i mean yeah i don't know i i
think
i would still work just to stay [ __ ]
busy and mobile and everything but the
guy was filthy stinking rich
that's how you know someone will never
have money when they say filthy stinking
rich
you've said it before no i haven't
you've never said it i've said it
multiple times
and he'll never have money oh we were
talking about the money from the patreon
he's like so you're telling me in a year
i won't have to save money and we're
like
oh god this is bad this is real bad
i'm spending it like water oh [ __ ]
dude that i i've heard that phrase in so
long
spending money like water spending money
like what up there oh my god
real truth is that what you
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] now we have a list of uh
no not really yeah i mean uh you know
uh the lists weren't uh that adequate so
i figured we would just talk
all our stories of uh you know what all
right so the big thing for us growing up
was the distance and the distance where
you would get a coach botched a
coach bus versus a school bus
really yeah who the [ __ ] if it was over
that two hours they had to give you a
coach bus so you could go to the
bathroom i guess so that's what they did
so when you own two hours away in a
field trip i mean we we
we would do like harrisburg for like
social there was like a new york trip
that
i vaguely remember going to new york
when i was in like four years yeah we
were supposed to that
ain't 11. no we're supposed to do uh new
york and dc
how old were you when 9 11 happened uh
34 no
uh where were you at 9 11. yeah where
are you i was in building 7 no uh
i was ninth grade eighth or ninth grade
something like that ninth grade okay
yes like thirteen how old are you now
thirty-six
yeah thirty-four i mean that was
twenty-three where are you living on a
prayer
[Laughter]
in a chair
i didn't get it but i'm laughing at it
you didn't get it
living on a prayer while we're halfway
there you were eating in a chair
is that a part of the song this guy's
trying to kill them
henry and i'm no longer the dumbest guy
yes i apologize um
but that was the big thing and then the
other big thing was snacks the night
before
as we would hit like i would go i would
you got a bigger lunch i would go well i
would make my
dad either go to wawa the night before
or that morning on the way to school
because my dad would always use to drive
me to school because the school bus
wouldn't pick me up at his house oh we
had we would go on
and like uh on road can i have one of
your gummy worms
we would uh we would have we would go to
a rest stop
and as a class as a class and we'd have
to wait hopefully get job applications
that was a we're gonna take a walk to
the future
and uh you're gonna see where you're
gonna end up mr brian when are we
getting to the field trip ian you're at
the field trip
now the man said twenty dollars on pump
four a delaware field trip is going to
where the needles get made
now put this hair net on and go drop
those fries
everybody's joke was worthy god damn
included i flubbed toby flooded tight
ian folded the best day and he had a
pair of deuces [ __ ] kenny rogers over
here
ian had the wheels oh he's all in on a
2-4 officer
toby shook it took a shot at it i raised
him fully
fully went all in
[Laughter]
hit me i had that seven deuce in philly
and i brought it over to delaware
oh my hernia hurts me
oh [ __ ] hernia acting up god
dude i had hernia surgery back in like
20 to
2003 and when i laugh real hard i can
feel it sometimes
sounds like a good doctor yeah with the
amish do that
oh baby the snake and the sizzle
he can bite down on this duck
i was going to make the joke i backed
out because you came in like a [ __ ]
big
ducks that was hack
you know get the jamaicans in here we
got to stage this joint real quick
lord of mercy that was bad what are you
doing by
that's your bad your instinct man
you three stink man
look look what washed up on the beach
the accent was terrible this could be
the worst podcast ever
i don't know i got so excited
what you doing over there on the beach
in a fat whale
i was more of a pirate than anything no
are you gonna finish that gar i'd be
licking bob marley man
did you hear him
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we're having a good time
my god
[Music]
so the hatfield plant back to the ham
you just looked at toby like you were in
speed you're trying to fight that guy
has ever you guys ever been to six flags
we went we went one time uh our homet
class junior year went to
this real family i took home eck yeah
did you learn how to expand the waste
language
i mean i saw it coming from a mile away
and you couldn't get it
that was a [ __ ] it's like a bird
flying in delaware that's at the end of
this [ __ ] rookie of the year it's in
slow motion i still missed
[Music]
floated
jesus christ can't you learn how to
expand your weight band on your belt
no we just cooked we actually learned
how to make a proper pasta dish
i got extra points
they took us to this they they took our
homemade class which was me one of my
friends
and um uh you know the teacher i'm
getting a bunch of other kids yeah
i don't know what's happening here i
think we should stop it we think we
should stop
i think we should stop doing the podcast
i don't know i don't know what was wrong
nothing's working
we don't know what the hell we were hot
up top
it's actually 300 kids man it was the
biggest field trip of the year
uh we went to this indian joint and
nobody ate anything none of us would we
staunchly
american indiana
because i went to the scared of the corn
i went to the churchville nature center
and they gave us like native american
snacks i took one bite out of like a
corn patio okay anybody want my antler
[Laughter]
i ain't antler for lunch i'm good
i stopped the wawa i packed my own
antlers
i had some on the bus same seats on the
way back by the way
oh [ __ ] are these bears eyeballs
these are pretty good that's not good
bears god damn it wow we'll always have
antlers
we gotta wrap just wrap it just wrap it
gang this is supposed to be the field
trip episode
which went off the rails pretty quickly
unfortunately
thank you for tuning in we love you guys
and we'll see you guys next week i'll
see you guys thank you
peace